I love Mexico if we stand complicit that
we see avec vous it's I'm delighted to
be here probably one of the few if not
the only non AI person here in the room
so it's been quite a learning experience
this entire day before starting I want
to congratulate the winners of the the
poster presentations I think it's very
important that we keep all this
creativity going on in in Canada I want
to thank also the the people who asked
the last questions about transparency
about predictability etc because that
was a great act actually miss insan' for
our own panel here and and last but not
least I want to congratulate everyone in
this room and who's not in this room but
as part of this gathering and thank you
actually for the science excellence
dedication and incredible creativity
that has ensured that Canada remains at
the leading edge of artificial
intelligence so there have been a lot of
conversations since yesterday that I
heard about AI applications transparency
impact on society and and so on and
before asking each of the panelists to
introduce themselves we have a superb
actually interdisciplinary panel here I
just like to reflect for a minute or so
on the impact the societal impact and
the societal licence of new technologies
so as we heard from the questions and as
you know and as I've heard over and over
from going to schools where I'm
encouraging boys and girls to go into
STEM disciplines people ask questions
about AI about robotics whether you know
the world is going to
taken over by non-human and I think that
we should all pay attention to these to
these questions and I'll tell you why
because many many years ago I was part
of a another sort of disruptive
technology and and revolution in the
life sciences which is known as genetic
engineering that assured a number of
very important and interesting things
from biotechnology in the agriculture
sector to the sequencing of the human
genome and with it a lot of ethical
conversations but with it also in
certain countries the social licence for
applications and innovations were
actually not granted and as a result the
society could not benefit from all the
great investments and all the great
advances that had happened in terms of
the science and the technology so if
history you know should tell us any
lesson I think it's that as we are as
you are creating these incredible
advances that are revolutionizing our
world I think that we need to have a
social dialogue and bring along people
and people are worried about a number of
things and we're gonna try to address
them so without any further further ado
I'm going to ask the panelists to please
introduce themselves say a few things
about your respective areas and any
thoughts but don't take a lot of time so
that we can have a conversation and
hopefully with the audience as well okay
so my name is Shai bin David I grew up
in Israel I did my PhD in pure
mathematics in set theory axiomatic set
theory and then I moved to computer
science and was for 17 years the
professor of the Technium Israel then I
moved to Cornell and 15 years ago I came
to Canada to what
and I'm focusing on machine learning
mainly theory a lot work recently about
clustering and in the past year I've
been turning my attention to fairness
and explained ability interpet ability
of machine learning which i think is a
very important aspect that should
deserve more attention thank you so I'm
not gonna yak I'm professor of
philosophy at the University of Montreal
so I feel deeply the impostor syndrome
right now that's so I I hold a PhD from
Bahia sovereign nice it feels very
ethical and political philosophy um I
forget it with Milla where I lead a
laboratory at gora and it's an
interested interdisciplinary laboratory
and I think in interdisciplinarity is
very very important when it comes to the
societal impacts of a I am how to frame
the issues other societal impacts of AI
I'm also mm cut director responsible for
deliberation at the observatory on the
societal impact of AI finally I sit on
the Advisory Council of Canada with Mona
and ELISA and there were people in the
room my research focuses on the
normative ethics of AI so I said I
initiated the material decoration for
responsible development of AI which is
basically a crowdsourced
framework for the development of AI and
so my research focuses on both
deliberative ethics of new technologies
and of
also on topics like it's been ability
interpretability fairness well we will
discuss this together okay
thank you I'm Fernando Diaz I'm Milla
affiliate but based at Microsoft
Research in morale so my background is
an information retrieval or applied
machine learning but in the last I'd say
five to six years in working with some
of the largest machine learning systems
in the world you begin to recognize some
of the things that happen at the
interface of society and the AI that
were deploying so these include things
like algorithmic bias include things
like propaganda and other ways that the
system can fall short of the social
expectations that we have and so to that
end we've started the the fake team in
Montreal fairness accountability
transparency and ethics that really
tries to address the societal impacts of
artificial intelligence and study it
from a multidisciplinary perspective
including not just folks from machine
learning theory computational social
science but also people from the social
sciences because we feel like that gives
us a really a holistic perspective on
the problem okay well thank you this is
gonna be a very interesting I think
conversation so so transparency fairness
explica bility what are the the great
advances or what are the things that we
need to focus on both from a scholarly
scientific activity and then maybe in
terms of engagement with the public I
think that the first problem is there is
a big gap here between there's a lot of
awareness to the importance of a
interpretability of extreme ability or
fairness you have the European Union
that passes regulations the
requires it from any application that
affects humans but there's a big gap
between this and how much we really
understand those things and how much we
can formalize it and evaluate how I mean
I heard a lot here during the previous
panels people talking about that they
would like a machine learning to be more
expander stand machine learning
understand how the algorithms work like
you were asking just a minute ago and
I'm asking what do we mean by understand
what is the meaning of that how do we
understand to understand and I think the
the big gap here is between how much
these topics are important and affecting
the applications is you we all know you
know doctors will not employ anything
that we develop if they don't understand
how it works but what do we mean by
understand how it works so the huge gap
between how important it is and how
little we have come towards say
developing a reasonable solid theory to
support these issues you know I listen
to you and before I ask the others to
weigh and you mentioned the doctors
actually in probably you guys prefer not
to know but for most diseases we still
don't know you know how to cure them and
when when you get a drug in most cases
it's still trial and error that the
doctor cannot understand the mechanism
by which it's working
I guess if everybody knew that that'd be
scared and would not take any drug so
how do you how do you manage you know
what how to explain to society the
unexplainable and sort of you know
reassure them or bringing them along
market own you must think about these
things yeah well so first of all I
totally agree about we still need to
understand what it means to to
understand we we have to understand what
is a human explanation human relevant
explanation and it's different
from the the explanation of the
algorithm itself or how it works in the
inside of of its but we need to
understand that an algorithm is embedded
in the system and the system is embedded
in in a social and tech technical social
network where you know the system
provides decisions and we have to
understand decisions in the light of the
other systems in the in the network so
if we want to explain how it works we
need to understand how it is embedded in
the network of well system able to make
decisions not only artificial systems
but also the people and institutions etc
so we need to get rid of the idea that
we can understand an artificial
intelligence system isolated from the
other systems and then we can build a
new understanding of how it works
because it works only when you know it
is a load to give some recommendations
or or a tool to provide us with
decisions etc this is where we have to
interact with AI systems and and then
it'sit's the the explanation will come
from the interaction not not only
explained the the the isolated system
and this is very very important because
even for people we're not isolated we're
not isolated systems when you ask me for
an explanation of any decision I make I
will late I will relate to other people
and decisions made before so Fernando I
if I try to make it simple okay this is
and
ái scientists so you see how difficult
it is I guess were you know your non
scientist out there in the public so
let's say that there are then two
components one is the individual
developing the algorithm because the
algorithm I guess you know has
interacted with a person and then there
is also the data on which you know the
machine learning and the interactive
thing is going to happen which has been
also built by human so how do you go
about you know ensuring or you know
protecting against buying biases or or
having the diversity needed and
reassuring people that this type of
context has been taken into account yeah
I think there's there's a few answers to
that so for one I think I think we need
to step back and think about the what it
means to ensure ensure fairness because
I think the first question we need to
ask is what does it mean for something
to be fair at all and I think in the in
the research community right now that's
that's even contested certainly within
the computer science definitions of
fairness there's there's several
different definitions but then if we
start to incorporate definitions from
outside of computer science which are
perhaps more well grounded there's not
one right answer so it's going to be
very contextual so let's assume that we
have some some agreed-upon definition of
fairness even then it's unclear whether
or not that biases are solely coming
from the data set they can be coming
from the way the algorithm is actually
decided designed and what it's paying
attention to
moreover increasingly we have algorithms
which are not just fed a static data set
they're actually collecting the data on
the roses and reinforcement learning
where the it's it's it's it's I don't
think of it less as a data set than a
set of experiences that the agent is
actually gathering and then the agent
can gather things in a biased way now
where is that bias being introduced well
it's being introduced because of the way
the algorithms being designed and so how
do we actually think about designing a
system to collect data so that it is not
susceptible to bias
but that's that's a few steps down I
think we need to we need to start at
finding fairness from the start
would you like to weigh in on the
fairness part yes I said I think the
fantasy and as you were saying I mean we
we don't have a single definition and we
can see that different definition that
each of them makes sense on its own when
you compare them then contradictory in
in certain areas and my kind of fair
assumption it's not that I can prove it
is that we will need different notions
of fairness for different applications
for different purposes we cannot find
the one definition that fits for so the
furnace for accepting students
University may be different than the
furnace for policies of a hospital of
who should get a kidney before whom or
different from the fairness of the
judical system that decide on unveil so
I think one of the things that is not
recognized well enough yet is that
furnace is not a unique well defined
issue but it could be really context
dependent and it also depends on the you
know more violent and fundamental
principles of the person who applied the
resource that we want to provide I mean
what is more important to me to have
more minorities in my program or to get
everybody the fair chance in the sense
of if you got higher marks in school you
should go there first and I think I mean
last thing I want to kind of mention in
this context is that I think it is very
important for us to be more open and
more connected communicating with people
outside the area of computer science so
I think like the talk of Kandi's earlier
or talks that I mean I was in a in
seventh Institute in a
program on unfairness and affordability
and my conclusion is that the most
insightful talks were from people who
came from outside computer science in
mathematics from people who are
sociologists for people who are working
with law from people who are
philosophers and we I think we need more
interaction with those outsiders so I'm
just wondering I agree with you by the
way because I think that you know AI is
going to be an enabling technology and I
look forward to actually to the next
panel as well on health to see how we're
gonna do this but in the meanwhile what
what you feel you know like it's
Canada's leading in this area or there
you know other jurisdictions that we can
learn something from even if we're
leading what needs to happen for you
know all of what you've been you know
alluding to to sort of happen even more
that's why you're here you're mixing two
questions it's not clear to me where
your focus is it's about is it about
Canada is about what the science needs
to do what does the science need to do
and what does the science of also
interacting with society you know needs
to do so you know both anyway anyway and
you know are can we learn from anyone
[Laughter]
maybe before I just wanted to add that
you know philosophers grappled with the
idea of fairness for more than 2,000
years and the only consensual definition
is that furnace is about treating
similar case cases equally what what is
the dimension exactly exactly what is
similar it was and what is equally what
does it mean equally so well
we cannot go much further but actually
we can maybe go a bit a bit further if
you well if you put together if you
bring together just you know a small
number of experts and you ask them to
define to define fairness and to define
biases and to find a solution to this
question it's must it's most likely that
you will miss important aspects of the
questions and of the discussions because
a small number of experts will will
focus only on sir inspects at the
question and there will be very very
good at solving definite problems but a
lot of other problems will remain under
the radar so what we can do is open the
discussion and when I say open the
discussion is it's about bringing people
lay people as I am for machine learning
for instance into the conversation and
not because there are experts in the
scientific sense of expertise of being
an experts but because they know how the
system will be deployed and their daily
day-to-day life and then they can
highlight you know problems that we're
in Seattle for instance you want to
develop an AI system that's allow that
allows artists people to detect emotions
and then you do all the the work on the
scientific parts you provide the best
device and you're happy because people
now can detect and interprets the the
emotion on the face of their the people
they are interactively
now if you but citizens lay people in
the loop before designing this this
device maybe maybe you'll hear something
like oh well it's very interesting but
maybe I don't want to be interpreted by
your device and maybe we should you know
let's change the same the settings of
this device and this is the kind of
thing that we cannot get from just
expert panels so one avenue to explore
is to open the discussion deliberation
with lay people but we have to be very
careful because we need yes we need to
focus the discussion on certain points I
think I think that's a great point I do
and and I've been thinking along the
same lines and to be honest prompted by
a Georgina born if you're out there hi
to think about things like techniques
from design for example participatory
design that involves more of the end
user in the process and this sounds good
all right now the problem now connects
to previously what being talked we've
been talking about with explain ability
because I cannot bring in an end user
and sit them down in front of a machine
learning system and tell me and ask them
are you comfortable with this because
it's it's it's not super interpretive
all right now and so if we think about
going back to explain ability
interpretability this is one task that
you could imagine such a system being
used for on top of another task being
you know oddity in the system or helping
debug the system etc is for helping with
that design process so I'm going to open
it for questions from from the audience
and while you make your way to the
microphone I'm just gonna ask this this
question to the panelists it seems to me
that you know fairness transparency and
explain ability is an important area of
machine
so hopefully some of the students that
we have some of the students that you
have you know will will will help us out
but you know what would be some some
world of wisdoms or or or encouragement
that you would give the students I think
that the words of wisdom that I mean
that direction that definitely is that
don't get into the publication chase the
race of publishing I mean we're seeing I
think one of the diseases of this area
in particular in recent year or two of
fairness is that the huge number of
publications without much contribution
just because everybody wants to jump on
the wagon everybody wants to have a
paper with nibs everybody wants to have
his CV and with more items in it I think
even in a previous panel I held someone
saying you know his advice was published
when you publish only when you have
something to say in order to go to
academia you can postpone collecting
many many papers and I don't want to
postpone it I wanted to never happen I
think that we are drowning in too many
publications and especially in areas in
this area of recently of fairness and
machine learning and I think people
should hold back and think twice are
they sure that they have something
worthwhile to say thank you I think yes
I think it applies unfortunately too
many areas of science and you wanna know
something the word of wisdom for Everett
first let me think
remain curious and open-minded in this
area I see too many computer scientists
who think that if they can solve a very
complex mathematical problem then it
will
easy to settle any societal issues and
that's not the case and I see too many
philosophers sociologists the thing that
if we can agree on the high principles
and the high values then well the rest
is just a matter of technicality and you
know the computer scientists will will
do their job to settle those
technicalities so we need to learn
better from each other and it's been my
my advice yeah for me this is I think
something that men relevant also
mentioned in a panel at each guy 2005
which has become an expert in your own
area first and then collaborate broadly
I think I think this is a super
interdisciplinary area but I think it's
premature to say I'm gonna I'm just
going to focus on fairness I think you
really need to focus on your core area
be it machine learning be a be it
philosophy etc and then engage with an
open mind with the other disciplines ok
great thank you so we're gonna take the
first question I think someone is there
yep okay oh thank you thank you very
much for the engaging conversation and I
think I'm one of the few non people with
non technical expertise on computing
science here a the question that I
wanted to ask was on the role of
government in this context because we're
talking about how scientific community
should engage with each other and how
citizens should engage in this issue but
the success the point of talking about
fairness transparency and exploring
ability is so that those are reflected
in our day to day lives and with with
the premise that you know AI is a
technology that doesn't remain silent
within the university but affects the
lives of everyone basically out there so
in this context put putting it simply
should there be a bigger government or
smaller government in an addressing the
issues about fairness transfer
cien explain ability okay thank you I'm
going to ask the panelists to answer no
I think that I refer to Fernando you
think before you talk about fairness we
become an expert in your area now if I
want to apply it to the government I
mean my problem yeah it's a lifelong
project thing yeah I would like to see a
kind of regulations and guidance but I
don't trust their expertise and
therefore I will just step back and say
let let at this stage things just happen
because you don't understand the well
enough to enforce any rules of
directions yeah I guess I might be
dodging the question here but I do think
there's there's something to be said for
self-governance or pedagogy here insofar
as in let's say in an industry we're
noticing a lot of the problems that were
we've talked about today but the
students that we're hiring they're
ill-prepared to have discussions about
this they don't have vocabulary they are
not refined and thinking about things
like ethics or fairness etc and so to
the the real academics in the room III
would I would encourage you to think
about how to integrate this into your
programs
I guess not necessarily as a one course
ethics class that someone can sleep
through but really into the whole
program so that people when they
graduate and they some of them will
enter industry have that sort of way of
reasoning about the social implications
I'll give my my take on this at the end
please we have another question yeah
thanks for a really engaging
conversation I guess reflecting while
you were talking on the the opening
remarks about the importance of
maintaining our social license for the
work we do I think is a really valuable
viewpoint and on the other hand
something I really took from your
comments on the panel throughout our
that particularly fairness is really
thorny it's difficult to come up with a
definition
you know different definitions that all
seem sensible disagree and even
formulating what fairness means is
really kind of hard to come by
I wonder you're putting those two things
together surely you know if we're at
risk of losing our social license it's
not because we slightly got wrong the
definition of fairness and you know
misunderstood some edge case surely it's
that we would build a system that
egregiously fails in a way that you know
everyone would agree was a violation of
fairness you know that the different
definitions doesn't look at the
boundaries between different definitions
I wonder if there's a way forward at
least in the short term that works in
more negative terms that but thinks more
about kind of egregious unfairness and
you know what we have to certify that
our systems avoid rather than you know
aiming to optimize some kind of perfect
definition of fairness that's a great
question
can we get practical yeah I think it's a
very good question and I think you we
cannot he'll generalize but there are
different roles I mean if a company is
offering a tool for judges to decide on
bareness I want to have the tools to
monitor whether it's unfair or not and
in that respect I agree with you that
good tools will are necessary and we
should rather deploy them fast than wait
until we have a complete definition but
it's not exactly about the development
of the area as you were addressing or
the benefits for me I it's about how to
weed out a kind of a malicious players
in in the ground but it's not clear to
me how it applies to the development of
AI from the positive point of view
there's been a few papers in the last
year that have interviewed actual
machine learning engineers to better
understand what they're looking for in
in fairness tools and it's really the
case that they're asking for a better
fairness definition or even a better way
to devise something what
that means they're looking for cruder
sort of tools to understand datasets to
gather data better etc and so I don't
think this is answering the question
exactly but IIIi do i do think that yes
maybe we should be focusing more on what
the engineers etc are looking for right
now to avoid situations which companies
are dreading which is that blog posts
that ProPublica article that's going to
send their stock down a few points well
it depends some on the areas you you're
targeting so for instance if it's the
judicial system
well furnace is very very simple it's
just similar case should be treated
equally so if you're and it's it's very
simple to turn the Sun in the judicial
sector so for instance if you are asked
where I want I want to use other
classifications if you are square and
for an offense X you get ten years and
for the same offense if you were a
circle you get twenty years that's very
simple here to detect identify an unfair
treatment and maybe with different
techniques to identify the source of
this unfair treatment so we can use
counterfactuals we can use different
techniques to to try to identify the
source but here it's very very easy now
in health let's say you're a circle and
the machines that can provide a
diagnosis for a skin cancer so the the
machine are the machines are trained
only for the skin of circle people and
then you see that okay it works very
well for those people but it works
not that well for other people for
instance a square people well this is a
problem because you need to know where
where is the the source of the the bias
and here well it might be obvious but if
we don't have the same amount of data
for square people as for a circle people
sorry it's it's very weird to say that
but well you can say we should have the
same amount of data for both but now how
did you get those data equally for the
the two subgroups and there you can you
know it will be difficult to get the
same amount of data unless you have
biased approach to favor one subgroups
over another and so this is complex but
it depends on the area and I could yeah
so I guess you know what you're saying
is the whole fairness and ethical
considerations are gonna have to be
contextualized per sector like the
transport is one thing health is another
maybe etcetera etcetera yeah I think we
have a patient question waiting yes it
was question to fry and this is question
about your answer to one of the previous
questions I completely agree with what
you said about advice to students not
just to students I would say to all of
us to focus on harder more challenging
problems and avoid just generating many
many papers for the sake of numbers and
it's great advice and I'm also
mentioning it to my students
yoshua bengio mentioned that multiple
times during his interviews at AI week
at MIT for example and sons of course
it's great we all agree how do you
suggest implemented resource is limited
and therefore everybody's thinking about
this
how do you convince your students to
publish less than more there must be
some incentives or some metrics that
will make it advantageous for them
otherwise it's like it's a great idea
it's a great desire I totally share it
it's not practical yeah but I don't take
such an economical view or utilitarian
view of the life of academics I mean
there is a reason why we are in academia
and we are not in Google making three
times as much salary we also have
talking about money no I'm just saying
that we are not only motivated by a kind
of you say what mechanism could direct
people towards behaving in the right way
and I'm saying that your inner judgment
your self respect your own principles
should direct you and it should not
always only come from outside incentives
I agree but as we all know to be a
member of society and to be free from
society is impossible
you know whom I'm quoting so if I can if
I if I may just like maybe provide a
sort of answer I agree with you that the
the individuals are part of a system and
the entire system has to embrace the
same principles exactly whether it's at
the university for promotions or at the
granting Council for for basically
review so you'd be happy to know I don't
know if you guys have noticed that the
granting council in Canada have signed
to the Dora declaration which means that
it's not the numbers that count it's not
the impact factor of the journal or the
conference but it's the quality of the
work so let's keep the pressure on and
make sure that you know the peer review
system you know behaves that and in that
way because I think that but it's you
know a collective results thank you
that's that's exactly what I was talking
about thank you so listen
this has been a most exciting I think
dialogue I have not forgotten the the
colleague who has the question about the
role of government I would just like to
maybe in you know invite everyone here
to just think about what we can learn
from the past what can we learn from
disruptive technologies be it in
reproductive technologies beaten stem
cells etc and government's ended up you
know passing laws and so on but only
after there was proper societal you know
like conversations and expert advice so
I just like to say that everyone here in
this room actually does have a
responsibility to engage in that
dialogue in that thinking around what's
ethical what is it that we would you
know recommend that government does or
doesn't do I don't think that and I
agree with you sha I don't think that we
want at this stage to ask the government
you know to do this we need to rise to
the to the occasion and and make
recommendations but I do believe that we
have some work to go so thank you very
much
[Applause]